early on in your career when is just
first starting out you thought like hey
some of the work I'm doing is this is
oscar-worthy stuff oh yeah yeah I mean I
remember when we did dude where's my car
I was like I looked at Ashley remember
really good fun movie but also one of my
favorite titles of all time for a movie
it's a great time it's a great title but
I it was upsetting though you know the
making the movie I remember Ashton and I
you know we're like we got a chance to
win some awards for this thing temmie
awards that you wish how old were you at
the time I was like 23 yeah yeah and and
when we didn't get nominated I thought
you know then you know didn't Melissa
McCarthy get nominated for bridesmaids
yeah I think I thought all right then
all right you know what finally you know
we're getting recognized for our work
you know the comedy stuff but I thought
if dude where's my car came out right
now I would win some medals yeah you
don't get Nettles I love that your dream
is to win one of those medals at the
Academy Award that's so perfect didn't
you tell me once that you guys had the I
perfect name for the sequel for dude
where's my car
yeah what seriously dude where's my car
[Laughter]
[Applause]
please make that me cuz I'm a member
like when Ashley and I was like you know
you're like you're like Brando and I'm
Pacino in this thing
what's so funny Oh I mean I'm agreeing
that's how I agree with people yeah I
agree with you five laughing